und es wurde ja gekündigt das habe ich
euch ja letztens erzählt das heißt wir
müssen zum 31 januar hier raus sein aus
unserer wohnung danke noch die ganzen
lieben wünsche und so weiter die uns
geschickt habt das ist wirklich
unglaublich ich bin total überwältigt
von euren ganzen lieben nachrichten also
nochmal da wir haben auch schon einige
höfe angeschaut die uns geschickt habt
es ist leider sehr sehr schwierig für
uns etwas gutes zu finden weil ich hab
mir schon erzählt mein freund und ich
haben so ein bisschen unterschiedliche
vorstellungen ich verlinke euch nehmen
wir das video zum umzug unten in der
video beschreibung falls sie das noch
nicht angeschaut habt aber wir haben
zwei konkrete sachen die wir uns
wirklich gut vorstellen könnten die kann
ich euch auch noch mal am ende
vorstellen damit ihr up to date seid was
ich da bisher für uns ergeben hat das
sind auch ganz spannende sachen mit
dabei vor allem eine sache aber an sich
wenn ich es schön wenn wir jetzt erst
mal träumen weil ich so ein bisschen von
den träumen erzählt habe die ich in mir
habe und die ich einen neuen hof gerne
umsetzen würde haben ganz viele von euch
geschrieben dass sie genau solche träume
auf haben und das total schön finden
davon zu hören
deswegen möchte ich euch gerne einladen
mit mir ganz große wilde verrückte
selbstversorger träume zu spinnen heute
und mal zu überlegen wenn alles möglich
werde was würden wir dann am liebsten
alles draußen machen welche tiere würden
wir gern haben was wollen wir gern
anbauen in niefern wollen wir uns selbst
versorgen wie ist das eigentlich mit der
selbstversorgung mit energie und strom
und so weiter da hab ich ja noch nie
glaube ich auf meinem blog und auch auf
dem kanal darüber gesprochen es wäre
jetzt einfach mal von meinen ganzen
wilden träumen erzählen die ich so in
mir habe und dann freue ich mich total
unten in den kommentaren austauschen
können und ihr auch und euren träumen
erzählt und vielleicht auch mal erlaubt
überhaupt so wild zu träumen und zu
schauen auch wenn es nicht sofort sein
muss aber wo man denn eigentlich hin
will mit seiner selbstversorgung ich
will natürlich auch wieder einen schönen
gemüsegarten haben ich freue mich total
wenn wir an dem hof ankommen und den
garten am haus haben können das ja ist
zum teil jetzt für uns gerade nicht
möglich weil wir ja unser ganzes acker
gemüse weiter weg anbauen müssen weil
wir hier nicht genug platz haben
das heißt wir müssen immer mit dem auto
da hinfahren und sind da eigentlich nur
so alle paar monate mal weil es schon
ein ganzes stück weg ist und wir mal
viel zu tun haben deswegen sind wir
eigentlich nur zur aussaat da dann
vielleicht mal zum kartoffeln häufeln
und dann wenn die erntezeit kommt und
zwischendurch kriegen wir davon aber gar
nichts wird es dann immer eine große
überraschung wenn wir dahin kommen aber
eigentlich würde ich mir wünschen auch
das ak gemüse also kürbis kartoffeln
karotten zwiebeln mais und so weiter ein
bisschen mehr bei mir zu haben und
eigentlich einen großen gemüsegarten wo
wir das feine gemüse dass wir regelmäßig
ernten und essen und das akademische
zusammen anbaut oder das zumindest alles
bei uns in der nähe wäre
ansonsten bin ich mit der garten größe
die wir haben total zufrieden also wir
haben ungefähr 300 quadratmeter reine
bildfläche also ohne wege ohne die
flächen zwischen den beeten und damit
kommen wir ziemlich gut hin ich habe
jetzt dieses jahr angefangen auch hart
mais anzubauen zum backen und für poland
habe vorher nicht gemacht und dadurch
kennen wir auch wieder mehr kartoffeln
anbauen und weil dann unsere fahrzeuge
besser ab als wenn die ein bisschen mehr
fläche hätten als diese 300 quadratmeter
also ein bisschen erweitern würde ich es
gerne aber im prinzip bin ich mit meinem
garten sowie der jetzt ist voll und ganz
zufrieden der versorgt uns das ganze
jahr über mit gemüse und obst natürlich
weiß ich nicht ob da jetzt auch
obstbäume haben werden wo wir hin ziehen
oder ob wir die komplett neue pflanzen
müssen aber das ist ja das ist ein ganz
anderes team war so einen anwalt oder
nach startenden waldgarten finde ich
auch super spannend wenn man wenn man
den selber anlegen kann aber natürlich
wäre es auch toll wenn da schon
obstbäume werden nur weil sonst dauert
es ewig ist man dann zum ersten mal die
eigenen äpfel werden und so weiter
lernen kann nüsse sind auch etwas kummer
nüsse sind so nahrhaft ich würde total
gerne viel mehr nüsse sammeln und ernten
und deswegen fertig ist auch total
wichtig wenn wir dann an unserem hof
oder in unserem haus ankommen da
ziemlich bald die ersten bäume zu
pflanzen
oswald anzulegen geben weil es so lange
dauert bis man die erste ernte bekommt
wer das so mein allererster schritt an
dem neuen hof dass wir schauen welche
obstbäume gibt es und dann die anderen
ergänzen die pflanzen weil es nämlich
ewig dauert bis man da die ersten
erträge hat und deswegen würde ich die
nuss und obstbäume immer direkt als
erstes in die erde bringen falls es von
der pflanzzeit her ungefähr hin kommt
ansonsten natürlich auch beerensträucher
und alle mühe gegeben gewächse wohl ein
bisschen länger auf die ernte
man muss das wäre so mein allererstes
projekt auf dem neuen hoch sobald alle
tiere untergebracht
übrigens habe ich nach der haare ich
hoffe es sieht nicht so aus als hätte
ich irgendwie seit wochen nicht
gewaschen im gegenteil ich bin gerade
aus der dusche wichtigen und weil geist
so einem haus besichtigungstermin müssen
habe ich es nicht mehr geschafft zu
warten bis die haare trocken
dann gibt es auch so abgefahrene sachen
freund von mir hat mich letztens damit
angefixt kennt ihr indianer bananen sind
anscheinend krisen große bäume die man
auch hier in deutschland anbauen kann
die früchte haben die ähnlich wie mangos
sind irgend mich ich bin schon ein
freund so ein bisschen verrückte sachen
dann auch mal auszuprobieren und es wäre
einfach total schön wenn wir dafür dass
genug platz hätten aber was ich auch
super cool findest akku vorerst also
bäume mit ak zusammen nebeneinander
pflanzen oder beugen mit tieren zusammen
also nur streuobstwiese ist sozusagen
auf eine akku forst system weil der
bäume sind und darunter leiden dann zum
beispiel schafe das wären sie wohl
pastorales abgassystem man kann das aber
auch mit beeten machen niemand zwischen
den bäumen anlegt und das hat ganz viele
unterschiedliche vorteile das ist super
spannend also gerade in die richtung
regenerative landwirtschaft da gibt es
so viele tolle idee und ich finde es so
schön wenn wir den hof haben könnten wo
man diese sachen ausprobieren kann und
wir haben ja auch eine große plattform
über die wir super viele leute erreichen
so dass wir dann unsere erfahrungen
teilen können und hoffentlich dann ganz
viele nur im ganz viele keimzellen
entstehen von leuten die auch lust haben
wie essen auf eine bessere art und weise
anzubauen zu wissen wo es herkommt und
dass richtig richtig gut zu machen und
das ist mein großer traum mit diesem hof
und ich brenne total dafür
diese sachen ausprobieren auf wales und
techniken aus der firma kultur
da ist alles so buzzwords aus der
regenerativen landwirtschaft die
wahrscheinlich vielen von euch jetzt gar
nicht so viel sagen aber ich habe total
lust daran was ändern und impulse in die
welt zu setzen und diese sachen
auszuprobieren und zu schauen wie kann
eine zukunftsfähige landwirtschaft oder
eine zukunftsfähige subsistenzwirtschaft
aus dem und ihr merkt schon da gibt es
tausend sachen die mir die mir im kopf
herumschwirren und die ich super super
gerne umsetzen würde und es wäre so
schön wenn wir die demnächst an einem
ort ankommen würden wo wir das alles
machen können aber dann haben wir
natürlich nicht nur zwei sondern wir
haben auch die tiere fange ich mal mit
dem ziel
wir haben im moment fünf stück meiner
ganz alte liebe uralte anna ist leider
letztens gestorben aber die ja sie hat
glaube ich 14 jahre auf dem buckel
gehabt und das ist schon echt nicht
schlecht sie hat arthrose und es war
eigentlich nicht schlecht dass sie jetzt
vor dem winter gegangen ist weil sie im
winter im arge probleme mit der kälte
bekommen hat und so ist ihr das immerhin
erspart geblieben aber es ist trotzdem
total traurig also haben wir jetzt nur
noch 15
von ganz unterschiedlichen rassen und
ich merke nach immer mehr
ich hatte lange nur fleisch ziegen und
bin dann vor ein paar jahren auf
milchziegen sozusagen umgestiegen weil
wir eigentlich kaum fleisch essen oder
nur sehr sehr
sehr wenig und das ist uns eigentlich
viel wichtiger ist dass sie von den
ziegenmilch bekommen dass wir unseren
eigenen käse machen können und ich war
selber fast zehn jahre vegan weil nicht
das so schrecklich findet dass zum
beispiel die mütter von ihren kindern
getrennt werden und dass sie kühl nach
kürzester zeit ausgelaugt sind und zum
schlachter gehen und das kann man eben
wenn man es selber macht besser machen
ist es selbst wer denke ich tiere
wirklich artgerecht zu halten aber wir
versuchen es so schön zu machen wie wir
irgendwie können und sind sehr froh dass
das sehr harmonisch funktioniert
mittlerweile es für mich bekommen
trotzdem die zicklein bei den müttern
bleiben können und wir einfach nur so
viel nehmen wie übrig bleibt für uns und
da haben wir im moment eine wichtige die
wir im moment noch melden die ist jetzt
aber prächtig und deswegen werden wir
demnächst auf hören dass sie ein
bisschen der schonzeit hat aber da
können wir uns auf jeden fall auf
nachwuchs freuen nächstes jahr
ansonsten steige ich aber gerade auf
eine neue ziegen rasse um und ich habe
ewig nachzucht ihren von dieser rasse
gesucht also das heißt an lobbyisten der
milchziegen raste mit schlappohren und
die sie total sie es aus und die sind
total charmant und entspannt andere
rassen wie zb die paar winzige von der
wird auch noch eine ziege haben sind wie
ursprünglicher und dadurch haben die
viel schneller ab die kommt einfach über
den zaun rüber wir haben schon die
höchsten zäune die s14 zu kaufen gibt
und die springt da rüber als ob das
nichts mehr als ob derzeit überhaupt
nicht existieren würde die berührt den
noch nicht mal wenn sie darüber springen
weil diese rasse möchte ich auf jeden
fall nicht mehr halten weil das ist
jetzt schon die vierte dritte oder
vierte ziege von dieser rasse mit der
ich genau diese erfahrung gemacht habe
leider
deswegen steigen wir auf angriff um und
ich habe endlich von einem halb
zwei wunderschöne angebot via mädels
bekommen das heißt das ist die rasse auf
die ich mich jetzt konzentrieren
die haben eine super milchleistung sind
super hübsch und charmant und zutraulich
und überhaupt die hühner wollen wir
natürlich auch weiter halten da werden
wir uns im frühling auch ein paar neue
hennen zu liegen eventuell von rettet
das huhn die kennt ihr bestimmt wenn ihr
euch mit ihnen beschäftigt sie das nicht
kennt es ist eine ganz tolle sache da
kann man ausgedienten legehennen aus der
massentierhaltung noch mal ein schönes
zuhause geben meiner erfahrung nach
legen diese händen auch weiterhin noch
relativ gut da weil das hybrid hühner
sind die sind auf eine hohe leistung
ausgelegt so dass man trotzdem noch ab
und so ein frühstücksei von ihnen
bekommt aber es ist einfach schön wenn
man den platz hat und es den hühnern
erlauben kann wenn man solchen hindern
dann einfach noch ein schönes zuhause
schenken ich habe glaube ich auch einen
youtube-kanal den verlinke ich euch
gerne mal hier unten in der video
beschreibung und da können sie da mal
rein stellen also entweder wollen wir
uns von denen die ihn abholen oder von
irgendwelchen ebay kleinanzeigen
anzeigen wie kaufen eigentlich immer
gebraucht
da die irgendwo weg müssen weil leute
sie nicht mehr halten können und so
haben wir eigentlich alle unsere hühner
bekommen außer die beiden die wir
ausgebrütet haben was ich auch super
spannend finde auch wenn es mich ein
bisschen überfordern weil ich nicht so
der technik typ bin aber ich finde es
super schönen windrad zu haben um
unseren eigenen strom zu erzeugen
vielleicht auch solarstrom selbst
versorgung mit wärme
wer auch noch ein großes thema was wir
endlich angehen
wenn wir nicht mehr zur miete wohnen wo
es dann eben schon eine eingebaute
heizung gibt und man an der ganzen
infrastruktur eigentlich nichts ändern
kann
aber das wäre auf jeden fall auch noch
große projekte von denen ich ein
bisschen bisschen respekt habe weil ich
mich eben überhaupt nicht damit
auskennen
die ich aber total cool und spannend
wenn du ja und dann hätte ich so gerne
kühe
ich glaube wieder geld zu viel make der
kind diese sehnsucht so ein bisschen was
ich an kühlen so toll finde
wäre die möglichkeit sahne und butter
von der milch herzustellen und natürlich
dass man mehr milch hat sie sich auch
lohnen würde hartkäse oder schnittkäse
herzustellen im moment lohnt sich das
bei unserem ziel nicht weil wir nicht
genug milch haben um hat oder
schnittkäse herzustellen aber beinahe
kuvert das eben schon ganz anders und
wir verbrauchen der viel sahne sehr viel
butter und aus ziegenmilch sagen und
butter herzustellen ist sehr sehr sehr
schwierig also viel schwieriger als bei
kuhmilch hat deswegen wäre es für uns
ein großes upgrade wenn wir eine kuh
hätten ich denke einfach toll vor eine
kuh auf unserem hof zu haben einfach als
ruhepol gegenpol zu den ziegen die ja
schon einiges aufmischen und sehr sehr
charakterstark und wild sind und ja ich
bin für einfach klasse ich hatte super
super gerne eine kuh nicht melden kann
aber natürlich kann man nicht alleine
halten
also mindestens zwei kühe die milch
unbedingt enttäuscht wenn es nicht
klappt aber doch wahrscheinlich ja gänse
enten fände ich auch total und kaninchen
hatten wir auch schon mal dass wir die
auch super gerne weitermachen oder
wieder machen wird kaninchen traktoren
die kennt ihr vielleicht wenn ihr euch
damit immer beschäftigt habt ihr da und
dann noch eine sache die ich super super
toll fände werde ein erdkeller wo wir
unser wurzelgemüse lagern können wir
haben bis jetzt nur kleine ehrt mieten
aber so ein richtiger erdkeller das wäre
schon mega traum von mir ich bin eh so
vorratskammer sucht die ich finde das
kann man so ästhetisch und schön und bin
immer so stolz auf alles was wir wieder
in winterhalter machen
und wenn wir dann auch noch eine
erdkeller hätten wohl richtig viele
kartoffeln und so weiter ein lagern
könnten
das ist schon der hammer der ich hoffe
dass ich euch irgendwie inspirieren kann
auch größer zu träumen und ein bisschen
rum zu spinnen was man denn eigentlich
alles machen könnte und jetzt erzähle
ich euch mal von den beiden optionen die
wir bisher haben da tun sich gerade noch
mehr sachen auf also wie gesagt wir
gehen heute noch zu einer besichtigung
und morgen also wir schauen auch weiter
noch in andere richtungen einfach weil
wir uns noch sehr unsicher sind bei
diesen beiden möglichkeiten aber ich
fange mal mit dem spannenden projekt an
das ist ein ganz toller bauernhof hier
direkt in der nähe wo wir wohnen also
der schon auf dem land ziemlich auf dem
land mein freund ist nicht so begeistert
davon aber der hof hat eben super viel
potenzial und der ist total schön dann
haben wir uns da gemeldet und waren
jetzt schon mehrere male da ich habe
auch schon einen tag auf dem hof
mitgearbeitet und so noch mal den hof
noch mal von der anderen seite
kennengelernt und ein kälbchen aus der
kugel zu
an dem tag also da gibt es schon kühe
und da gibt es auch jede menge andere
tiere das ist ein richtig großer hof mit
25 hektar land so viel wollen wir eigene
nicht das heißt wir müssten das um
einiges verkleinern es gibt bis jetzt
sowohl sechs bis acht mutterkühe mit
kälbchen und zwei kühe werden gemolken
es gibt ich glaube ungefähr acht schafe
30 hühner wobei so viele waren es glaube
ich nicht es gibt ein erdkeller es ist
schon so viel darf und dem was wir haben
wollen es gibt wunderschöne stelle ein
sympathisches verschachteltes kleines
fachwerkhaus ist so alt ist und richtig
richtig urig und gemütlich es gibt zwei
große folientunnel es gibt gewiss gibt
kaninchen
es ist ein super toller ort nur das
alles noch ein bisschen größer ist als
wir es eigentlich haben wollen so dass
wir es noch mal irgendwie zusammen
einstampfen müssten es ist total
spannend aber gleichzeitig machen wir
das auch angst und riesensache zu
übernehmen es ist sehr viel möglich auf
die hofer hätten richtig viel platz
diese ganzen kiel ein design akku forst
und so weiter ideen auszuprobieren und
uns richtig richtig zu verwirklichen
wenn mein freund ist auch sehr
begeistert auch wenn es weit ab vom
schuss ist aber einfach durch die
möglichkeit dass wir dort gucken hin
holen könnten dass wir da vielleicht
auch politische arbeit machen können und
auf einer viel größeren skala noch etwas
bewegen könnten dass man dort im
veranstaltungsraum hätte für themen die
uns am herzen liegen dass man dort
korbflechter kurse und so weiter
veranstalten könnte vielleicht auch
leute von extern einladen könnte die
dort wissen vermitteln wollen was wir so
wichtig finden das alles wissen erhalten
bleibt ist hat super super viele
positive punkte aber dadurch das ist
ebenso groß ist und so viele
möglichkeiten hat es ist auch irgendwie
beängstigend für mich und ich wir müssen
uns jetzt demnächst mal entscheiden weil
wir da schon ziemlich lange drüber
sprechen mit den leuten und ich bin
einerseits total aufgeregt und würde am
liebsten sofort loslegen und habe schon
1000 sachen aufgeschrieben was ich da an
machen wollen würde und andererseits den
ich wie in so einer schockstarre und
möchte diese entscheidung eigentlich gar
nicht trennen weil ich da so respekt vor
habe ja die andere wirklichkeit die wir
haben also da sind wir noch nicht so
weit gekommen aber wir haben einen ort
gefunden an dem es bauland gibt auch
größere baugrundstücke hat sich auch
eine aktive frau gemeldet und uns davon
erzählt und wie steht es da superschön
und die andere möglichkeit wäre dann
also ein haus zu bauen was ich
eigentlich nicht so gerne will also es
wäre schon toll wenn man sich so richtig
verwirklichen könnte und alles so machen
könnte wie man will aber ich finde
eigentlich gibt es schon genug häuser
und genug flächenversiegelung und es ist
er auf eine art verlockend aber auf eine
andere art würde ich auch nur machen
wenn wir sonst nichts finden aber so
hätten die möglichkeit weiter in der
stadt zu wohnen aber am stadtrand dass
wir hinten raus ganz viele flächen
hätten die wir potenziell pachten oder
vielleicht kaufen könnten da müssten wir
dann schauen also sieht auf jeden fall
so aus als ob es da viele ungenutzte
flächen gibt und trotzdem in der stadt
werden so dass wir beide das bekommen
was wir wollen mein freund möchte nicht
so gerne auch dann tun
er ist auch nicht so der selbstversorger
typ und so würden sie eine lösung finden
die uns beiden auf jeden fall 100
prozentig zu sagen würde dass wir auf
jeden fall eine option über die wir auch
gerade nachdenken
aber wie gesagt wir schauen uns auch
weiter sachen an die eine sache die
wahrscheinlich feststeht ist dass wir
erstmal in eine wohnung umziehen werden
müssen wo wir keinen garten haben und
übergangsweise leben wir haben keine
wohnung jetzt hier in der stadt gehabt
die haben wir leider nicht bekommen ein
hauskauf dauert einfach länger als drei
monate
selbst wenn wir uns jetzt entscheiden
und jetzt irgendwas zu sagen wäre es
wahrscheinlich wird es wahrscheinlich
länger dauern als bis ende januar bis
wir dann umziehen könnten und deswegen
werden wir erst mal irgendwo anders
übergangsweise ein sie vielleicht wird
es auch ein längerer übergang werden wir
uns jetzt gegen all die sachen
entscheiden die gerade offen stehen weil
irgendwie doch nicht das richtige dabei
ist aber gute nachricht der garten den
wir hier haben den können wir weiter
nutzen solange wir noch übergangsweise
irgendwo wohnen also da an unsere
vermieter sehr lieb und die erlauben uns
dass wir hier weiter unsere sachen haben
auch die hühner können erstmal hier
bleiben die ziehen sind sowieso auf
einem anderen grundstück die einzige
sache ist dass wir dann etwas finden
müssen also eine übergangswohnung die
auch hier in der nähe ist so dass wir
weiter zu den hühnern morgens hingehen
können und auch zu den ziegen weil das
natürlich alles jetzt noch hier ist aber
wenn wir etwas finden was hier in der
nähe ist dann können wir auf jeden fall
alles erstmal so lassen das heißt wir
können den garten auch noch weiter
nutzen wir können unsere kartoffeln
ernten wenn alles gut geht und deswegen
suchen wir gerade sehr aktiv und ein
bisschen hin ring nach einer wohnung
direkt hier in der unmittelbaren
umgebung ist so dass das weiter
funktionieren würde hoffentlich klappt
das
oder wir finden so schnell etwas wo wir
umziehen können dass es irgendwie
trotzdem geht ja es wird alles gut
werden wir sind nicht mehr so schockiert
und getroffen wie wir es waren als wir
die kündigung bekommen haben das war
schon ein riesen schock
aber sie merken es tut sich was und es
entwickelt sich passen wir werden
dadurch es irgendwo irgendwann ankommen
auch wenn es vielleicht noch ein
bisschen dauert wo wir dann wirklich
alles
setzen können was in uns schlummert und
oder zumindest ein teil davon manche
sachen die ich euch heute vorgestellt
haben sind vielleicht ein bisschen
utopisch und ein bisschen zu groß sind
aber wie gesagt man muss seinen träumen
raum geben und die rauslassen und man
gucken wo gehen dass er als eigenen
eigentlich zieht also ich frage mich wie
gesagt wahnsinnig von euch zu hören
schreibt mir auf jeden fall was ihr
vorhabt unten in die kommentare
und wenn es nur heißt zum ersten mal im
frühling meine ersten beiden beete
anzulegen das ist schon ein super großer
erster schritt also ich hoffe dass ich
jetzt hier niemand irgendwie
untergebuttert fühlt wenn ich anfange
von kühen und kiel ein design zu reden
weil jeder schritt in diese richtung ist
wahnsinnig wertvoll und superschön und
egal wie groß oder wie klein deine
träume sind ich freue mich auf jeden
fall von dir zu hören ansonsten sehen
wir ins nächsten samstag wieder biss
dann schießt